Megan I'm going to break the cardinal
rule of pundits here and just say I
don't get it I don't get it I've now
watched this tape two or three times I I
don't get the police Behavior I don't
get obviously I don't get to Pap's
Behavior I don't totally get pulled I
just I just don't get it and and to to
your point we were given a narrative by
the doj we were given a narrative by
local police those were lies I don't get
why they realize I don't get why this
story became a huge National story to
the point that the president of the
United States gave a speech on it right
before the midterm elections and then it
just disappeared all of a sudden
everyone is acting very very sus to use
the language of the youths and uh
information